hey this is really crazy video
that people are up in arms about because
it is just so
whacked out this is video from july 31st
so the video is a month old a little
over just over a month old
but it somehow flew under the radar
until yesterday
donald trump did a round table on july
31st with the national association of
police organizations leadership
as a protest of uh as as a sort of
counter programming when protests of
police brutality
were raging in the united states at the
time
and very similarly to
trump's recent statements about what
happened in kenosha
about what's going on in portland trump
at this event
generalized that the protesters are the
violent anarchists
and they are determined to assault
police officers
police officers are in danger police
officers are the victims despite of
course being the ones who hold the power
in the power dynamic that exists with
law enforcement
and trump went off on a tangent about
protesters throwing things frozen
bottles of water
bricks whatever and then trump went into
a one-minute long bizarre attack
on cans of soup and bags of soup
what what the hell is a bag of soup the
video
somehow slipped under the radar back on
july 31st
it is something else take a look at this
it's water
and then they have cans of soup soup
and they throw the cans of soup that's
better than a brick because you can't
throw a brick it's too heavy
but a can of soup you can really put
some power into that right
and then when they get caught they say
no this is soup for my family
they're so innocent this is soup for my
family uh
it's incredible and you have people
coming over with bags of soup big bags
of soup
and they lay it on the ground and the
anarchists take it and they start
throwing it
at our cops at our police and if it hits
you that's worse than a brick because
it's got force
it's the perfect size it's like made
perfect
and when they get caught they say no
this is just
soup for my family and then the
media says this is just these people are
very very innocent
they're innocent people these are just
protesters
isn't it wonderful to allow protesting
no
and by the way the media knows it better
than we do they know what's going on i
don't know what's wrong with them
they're doing our country so the extra
component of
bags of soup is just extra funny it
reminds me of when trump
in one of those montages for the rnc
interviewed workers who had recovered
from covid
and one worker said i'm a custodian at
the post office and trump said oh oh
what what do you do and it was just one
of these moments where trump is just so
out of touch where he doesn't understand
what what a custodian does
you know most people who grew up in
normal childhoods know what a custodian
does
it does or do you know did uh
particularly if
you're proficient in english and this is
a similar moment where trump throws in
bags of soup now i have seen pouches
manishevits you can get a sort of pouch
of the dry ingredients which then you
mix with water
uh but i don't know that trump is
talking about those manishevitz pouches
when he talks about bags of soup but
listen i guess we have to take seriously
the weaponization of soup i've always
actually been a little suspicious
of so-called alphabet soup that sounds
weird to me
i don't know that that that seems a
little bit dangerous to me
of course you can only bag certain soups
like a bisque
probably does not lend itself to being
bagged
but i've had a bag of chowder before
both manhattan and new england style
clam chowder really really work well in
a bag
this actually really is uh
the exact type of trump going somewhere
in his mind
where we can't tell whether it's a joke
or something is wrong with him and of
course trump has no sense of humor so we
very quickly end up at like
something seems to be very very wrong
with this guy it's a delusional rant
about weaponized soup and then by the
way
worse than bricks like on the facts i
don't think that trump is actually
correct
and if you step back for just a moment
if this was your
relative wouldn't you immediately say
they need a full nero psych eval like
when we interviewed dr bandy lee
i guess it was three weeks ago now two
three weeks ago
and she said you know the the symptoms
are there to warrant
a neuro psych eval doesn't mean you're
diagnosing anything
but there's enough going on where you
would want that
does this qualify because this seems
very very strange
and it would be weird if it was anybody
in your family it happens to be the
president of the united states and as
usual it's like yeah people wrote to me
about how funny this is
it is funny it's funny in a superficial
way but once we're the laughingstock of
the world
and we're the pity of the world it's not
really all so funny anymore and it
actually hasn't been funny for a long
time
will we ever know the full truth of what
is behind rants like these
does anybody after the fact say hey mr
president you know sir
as he likes to say the material about
weaponized bags of soup
that was not so good that doesn't really
resonate with p with people
my belief at this point given what we
know about trump's personality
is that the people around him aren't
willing to go up to him and say that we
know that anybody who's willing to say
to trump what you're saying doesn't make
any sense
they don't last very long and we've seen
more than 500 people
move on from this administration over
the last four years i just don't think
it's welcome at all
if you've been watching the show you've
probably heard me talk about how much i
love
my helix mattress well i was really
excited to hear that helix has launched
a new company called
all form which makes premium
customizable sofas and chairs
with the same level of quality and
comfort
that i expect from these guys and all
form is one of our sponsors today
they're giving you twenty percent off at
allforum.com
pacman they actually sent me a couch
which i put
in my living room at home it's now my
favorite piece of furniture
in the house it took me just minutes to
set it up
it's solidly built it's huge it's roomy
it has a modern minimalist design which
i love but it's also
very comfortable fabric is soft clearly
very high quality
it has become the focal point of my
living room
their prices are very reasonable and
when you get a new sofa or
chair you get 100 days to decide if you
want to keep it and the best part is
everything comes with a lifetime
warranty
stop buying poorly made furniture go to
customize
your own all form sofa or chair right
now
and get twenty percent off your entire
order when you get there
by going to all form dot com slash
pacman
i've also put the link right underneath
this video